in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions John
and Cindy are with us hey guys how are
you
welcome welcome where are you from
Indianapolis Indiana all right very nice
good to have you in Nashville to your
debt-free scream yes how much have you
paid off three hundred and five thousand
dollars yeah that's impressive and how
long did this take oh eight and half
years okay we were all about mortgage in
three and then we paid the mortgage off
last Friday
got your ID so this is house and every
so awesome average household incomes of
the eight and a half years we started
about 120 finished at about 190
excellent great income what do you guys
do for a living I worked for an
insurance company at a Sheboygan
Wisconsin mm-hmm and I work for an
insurance agency in Indianapolis way to
go very cool excellent excellent so you
paid off the house yes yes it was a
journey was the house what's the house
worth 240 yeah okay and how old are you
do 55 both of us and you have a paid-for
house let's go paid for house you're
only 55 years old but most people think
they're gonna dot with the mortgage not
you we we did - we did - initially and
it took us a while to get here we had we
had a sewer backup that we didn't get
fixed right away we had an air
conditioner broke down that we went
without air for three years it worked it
worked unless it was like 80 degrees and
rule didn't work so that would not that
would not work so eight and a half years
ago what started this journey tell me
what happened I'm in the car a lot and
that was on the road and heard your
program by the second hour I was hooked
so I drove home then Cindy asked me hey
how was your trip
Oh Cindy Cindy Cindy said I heard this
County radio heard this kind of radio he
made a bunch of money with his younger
lost it all went bankruptcy now he does
financial counseling and we're gonna
follow his plan
no way like I had two heads and they
spent the next six months with Dave says
we should do this
dave says we should do that it was
offered at our church
yeah once it once it came to the church
and we attended FPU there and from the
first moment it's just like yes we will
do this and as soon as we got on board
together it was I won't say easy but it
it really it helped everything it helped
a relationship it it it was it's
wonderful and how much of the 300 was
the mortgage well there was we were
underwater on the house we had before so
it's probably 270 okay so you took three
years and paid off the other thirty
thousand first yes working the debt
snowball and in there we had two
weddings two cars we've cash flowed
three colleges free college education
whoa a plan we had a plan incrementally
step-by-step you fought through an eight
and a half years from the time you went
through Financial Peace University your
house is paid off and everything's paid
off one of the things I see here John
and Cindy is that your house your house
is only two hundred forty thousand and
for the income that you make I think
that's good for our listeners to
understand that all this was possible
because you're not in too much house you
guys and now here you are you're making
190 thousand you know I live in a two
hundred forty thousand dollar house and
yeah now you don't have a mortgage
payment so how in the world are you
gonna survive without them without it
and without the interest without the
interest deduction you know I've had
people tell me that we should not pay
off our house because of the interest
deduction oh that's okay what you said
before that if we'll go this way for a
while if we don't like it yeah we can
always go back mortgage yeah you can get
back into what do you tell people the
key is when they heard you got
completely out of debt and you've worked
this for eight and a half years that's
impressive
so when they hear that they they say how
do you get out of debt what do you tell
them the secret to getting out of debt
is work for me the first thing I had to
do
give myself some grace we'd all make
mistakes with money and things and once
I'd given myself some grace for my past
mistakes I just drew the line in the
sand we drew the line in the sand said
no matter what happens from this day
forward we are not going to do that
again that happen and that's that was
it's hard as everybody knows in this
society is that people something goes
wrong your air conditioner breaks
everybody goes out and puts it on
interest if you have to and get it fixed
so that was the hardest part but not the
hardest part that was hard it's not
caving in to everybody's expectations
you guys make great money why don't you
do this I wanted to do that it was like
no we have a goal and so the heart one
of the hardest part is just sticking to
it but it's it's worth it yeah we're not
borrowing the money for the wedding
we're not borrowing the money for the
college now we're not borrowing the
money for the cars you can all of that
while you were doing this yes and we had
a car blow up in there that we weren't
playing planning on replacing in for
another year so I had people say oh my
gosh you should buy a nicer car a bigger
car a better car we still upgrade it but
we had to go into our emergency fund to
pay for the car so we as Christa we just
stayed within what we had saved up and
that was that's that's the amount of car
I got that's perfect well I'm so proud
of you guys congratulations well done I
mean you are set with this income
heading into retirement it's gonna be
ding-ding-ding you're gonna be in a
great position to retire with dignity
and always be able to help others in the
process
thank you you'll be in a great place way
to go all right John and Cindy from
Indianapolis Indiana three hundred and
five thousand dollars paid off that's
house and everything in eight and a half
years making 120 up to 190 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
well Don you guys very well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show so you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind